the discipline of working in the clubs
the way that we all worked in the clubs
is now
it's not totally out the window but I
don't think we had no choice but to
grind in the clubs for years and years
and that's not a thing anymore it's not
as big of a thing as it used to be it's
interesting because you know podcasts
and Tick Tock and Instagram it's like oh
this is where I'm gonna have myself
because that's why am I why am I in the
clubs every single night right you can
be Loosely funny now versus having to be
when you're on stage it's like no it
needs to be exact right because you're
an audience is there and it's an
immediate reaction and now you can it
seems like you can shoot a bunch of
videos and then you just finally pick
one that works there's a big photo
Church
[Music]
oh wow
I mean that was crazy that almost
sounded fake yeah yeah yeah I mean
that's insane what does that mean what
God thinks I think that sounds like a
mortal sin to me yeah a big one it felt
like if it was done on purpose if it was
a little old lady that couldn't help it
yeah you know but oh that sounds like it
was done on purpose it sounds like the
devil pressing that button that had like
the club that's like
yeah those kids are videoing like those
kids went into that church and they
planned that yeah they found an old
church and they found a place to go do
it and they said there's a lot of that
that's what I'm saying it's like that
kind of stuff right this guy's probably
setting up yeah this guy could tell 200
tickets somewhere yeah yeah yeah there's
there's uh atheists right yeah but yeah
but he rolls out there and he brings a
small bench out there and he goes out
there and he gasses up with on the bench
and we were on the clubs like suckers
for years and we could have just been
doing Church farts yeah but the
longevity of it that's what that's the
thing longevity you can get people to
come and see you one time yeah but if
you don't give them something they're
not going to come back can you buy a
ticket to a show then you go see it live
you are seeing an act you're seeing a
proper Show versus yeah like you can
have videos where these people can sell
those tickets right and then you're like
they can't go do a full show it's hard
to learn how to do a full show that's
like sometimes you know like America's
Got Talent like when they would do stuff
like that then they give them like a
full they give them a year at Vegas
you're like some of these people are
like they've been doing this for six
years yeah yeah you can't go doing it
yeah they can't go do an hour like uh
he's like gargling like Jesse's Girl or
something you're like that dude can't do
an hour they can't do it there's no show
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one